Before Groot was the gentle giant fans know
and love today, he was a monster.
Literally.
A 125-foot-tall, rampaging alien monster.
He stayed that way for 45 years, too, until
a sudden and unexpected turn transformed him
into a hero and paved the way for his membership
in the Guardians of the Galaxy.
But during his five decades as a villain,
Groot caused quite a few problems — and,
honestly, that didn't really stop when he
joined the side of the angels.
As one of Marvel's monsters, Groot terrified
countless humans.
As a hero, he's always in danger of returning
to his villainous, uh, roots.
Here are just a few of the ways Groot has
terrorized the Marvel Universe.
Overlord of timber
It's hard to believe, but back in the early
days of Marvel Comics, Groot was there right
from the beginning, even before The Fantastic
Four and The Incredible Hulk burst onto the
scene.
In 1960's Tales to Astonish #13, Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby published a story called "I
Challenged Groot!
The Monster from Planet X," in which a tree-like
beast crashes to Earth and attempts to kidnap
the population of an entire city, hoping to
take his prisoners back to his home world
for nefarious experiments.
Normally, that wouldn't be a problem, but
superheroes didn't exist in the Marvel Universe
yet, so the village was officially boned.
That's because Groot isn't any normal alien.
He calls himself the "overlord of all the
timber in the galaxy" and gets stronger by
absorbing wood — no, really.
And not only can Groot talk, but he towers
above the villagers like some kinda Woodzilla,
destroying everything in his path.
Groot brings the local forest to life and
begins rounding up his human subjects.
Until, of course, one lowly scientist discovers
Groot's only weakness: termites.
As the insects chomp away at Groot's wooden
body, the creature withers and dies, leaving
Earth safe — for now.
Hulk smashed
The next time the Monster from Planet X appears
is in The Incredible Hulk Annual #5, in which
a recurring Marvel villain named Xemnu wants
to challenge the not-so-jolly green giant.
To do so , he resurrects Groot and a handful
of other old Marvel monsters — real cool
guys with names like Goom and The Electrifying
Blip.
Y'know...winners!
After smashing his way through a fifth-dimensional
demon named Diablo and a mud monster called
Taboo, Groot takes his shot at the Bruce Banner's
bigger half.
Groot's branches nearly choke the life out
of the Hulk, while planting his roots in the
ground makes Groot impervious to the Hulk's
gamma-powered punches.
Groot even whips out a wave of razor-sharp
thorns which seem all set to finish the Hulk
off for good.
But all of these attacks make Hulk angry,
and you know how that goes.
Hulk blocks Groot's attacks with a stone,
which he proceeds to use to beat Groot into
a splintered stump.
But that wouldn't be the end of Groot — not
by a longshot.
Breakout
Groot is a hard guy to keep down — remember,
he's grown back from a twig more than once.
In the 2005 one-shot Monsters on the Prowl,
readers learn that, at some point in the past,
the intergalactic super-nerd known as the
Collector rounded up all of Marvel's other
classic monsters and locked them away in an
underground prison.
That's weird and vaguely sinister, but relatively
safe — at least until Mole Man busts the
prison wide open, freeing Groot and the whole
monster party.
The army of monsters make their way from Canada
to New York, where they start stomping everything
in sight.
Unfortunately for them, Marvel's "good" monsters
— the Thing, the Hulk, Giant-Man, and Beast
— are on the scene.
Most of the monsters are easy pickings for
the experienced superheroes, but Groot puts
up a bit more of a fight, using his roots
to tangle up the Thing and Hulk.
But ultimately, he's defeated by the team
of heroes and locked away — although, obviously,
not for good.
Agent of S.H.I.E.L.D.
Groot's road to redemption begins in 2005's
Nick Fury's Howling Commandos mini-series,
but not before the arbor-alien gets in a few
more licks.
Under the leadership of S.H.I.E.L.D.
agent Clay Quartermain, the Howling Commandos
are a band of monsters charged with hunting
and capturing other monsters — and that
includes Groot.
Quartermain and his team find Groot hiding
in a forest, but the S.H.I.E.L.D. agents plaster
Groot with sonic weapons, eventually capturing
the titanic tree.
Groot's prison term is short-lived.
The evil wizard Merlin sends an army of goblins
and other supernatural creatures to attack
the Howling Commandos' base.
Quartermain opens the prison doors, freeing
Groot and the other prisoners, causing a stampede
that turns the tide of the battle.
While the other monsters flee, Groot stays
behind and helps the team.
Traveling on Groot's back, the Howling Commandos
take the fight to Merlin's stronghold and
put the wizard in his place — and give Groot
the redemption that he desperately craves.
We are Groot
Here's the big twist: the Groot who joined
the Guardians of the Galaxy might not be the
same one who terrorized Earth for 50 years,
since, apparently, everyone on Planet X is
named Groot.
"GROOT, GROOT, GROOT, GROOT, GROOT!"
That theory is confirmed in Guardians of the
Galaxy #14, which explores Groot's origins.
Before he left home, Groot lived peacefully
on Planet X, where a group of squirrel-like
"maintenance mammals" keep the forests in
tip-top shape.
One day, some young saplings decide to harass
one of the small critters, and that's when
the trouble starts.
Another young Groot — presumably, our Groot
— intervenes, saving the little creature's
life.
As the maintenance mammals thank the heroic
Groot for his interference, the other Groots
attack again, and that's when good-guy-Groot
tears them into pieces.
As punishment, the ruling Groots exile him
from Planet X.
Depending on how you look at it, Groot is
either a bully, a murderer, or both — so,
in a way, it doesn't matter if he's the same
Groot who debuted back in 1960.
He's damaged goods no matter what.
Groot, destroyer of worlds
Technically, this isn't something terrible
that Groot has done — it's something that
he'll do in about 30 years, according to an
elaborate virtual-reality simulation.
Rocket Raccoon #9 flashes forward to 2046,
and we see that Groot has returned to his
original, colossal size and plows through
New York.
He also plows through his longtime sparring
partner, the Hulk, who becomes a snack for
the rampaging monster.
As Iron Man explains, the Avengers tried to
use Groot's regeneration powers to cure all
diseases.
But, as is often the case when it comes to
comic book science, the process backfired,
turning Groot into a giant, mindless beast.
Tony Stark tracks Rocket down and tries to
enlist his help, but Rocket is old and bitter
and wants nothing to do with any of Earth's
heroes.
Meanwhile, the rampaging Groot tears S.H.I.E.L.D.'s
helicarrier in half, sending Steve Rogers
plummeting to his death.
Iron Man soon follows, smooshed under Groot's
wooden fist.
Rocket finally arrives, half-drunk, and transforms
his ship into a giant mech to fight Groot,
but it's no match for Groot's raw strength.
He tears both the robot and his furry friend
to pieces.
Still, it's not all in vain.
Rocket's sacrifice snaps Groot back to his
senses and transforms the monster into a giant,
life-giving tree, while Rocket goes down in
history as one of the world's most important
heroes.
"I am groot!"
"That's a really bad sign."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!